this one streamer who we're talking
about what's his name
uh xqc in this case
how much money does he make
he probably makes between
i wanna say three to ten million dollars
a year
no way really
yeah probably five to ten is the easy
estimate um ten man ten is not even the
upper bound like they
these guys can make much more than that
maybe
up to 20 25 million if they are
maxing out their stuff but they don't
always want to do that like uh i taught
because i used to negotiate with these
guys so you know um
even before twitch like when i was just
trying to get them to promote our
products
and it's like all right i'm going to
talk to i want to talk to the streamer
like no you don't get to talk to the
streamer you talk to the manager okay
fair that's fine they're stars i get it
all right who's the manager is it like
you know caa or like wme
and like for 95 percent of them it's
like oh it's like his little brother ray
ray yeah that was his girlfriend or like
you know exactly it's ray-ray or like oh
hey jenny um you know
so how long you guys been working
together it's like well we've moved in
together like when we were 16 and then
like he
didn't do anything for five years just
played video games all the time and like
now he's rich
and so i quit my job to like check his
email
[Music]
this is like the shirt it's like the
it's like the
gen y or gen x whatever what are the
young people now called what are the
what are the what does the young people
call it
it's like gen z it's like the uh tommy
bahama of gen z yeah i was i literally
was about to start with the shirt so
you're on to something what kind of what
brand is that
scotch and soda
uh yeah dude gotcha sort of crushes it
there was uh
two i was i went shopping this weekend
and um
like whatever the like union square in
san francisco and two dudes walked into
the uh elevator with their scotch and
soda bags and they were so
happy
it's like shopping makes people really
happy i think that's an underrated part
of shopping is how happy it made them
and they were just like
it was two guys and they were talking to
each other and they were still talking
about their shopping which i would say
i've never experienced that being
another dude just
first of all going shopping together
secondly after shopping not just being
like all right it's done whatever like
we don't even talk about it anymore
he was like yeah i'm really happy with
the color the guys again the color's
sick and i was like i'm just in the
elevator with them
and i was like i was like is that moss
green
[Laughter]
is awesome you shop there no i didn't
shop there i was shopping for my wife
but um
it's in the same like area whatever like
but you were shopping for her
like with her she wanted to go by i told
you she was trying to buy like a like a
designer bag which by the way it the
whole experience is crazy have you ever
done that have you ever gone like a
[__] you gotta make an appointment
yeah
well now they it's like a restaurant now
basically they uh you you go you put
your name down though like we'll text
you to get in like you can't just walk
into the store
yeah and um
we go in and it's like i've got two
babies and a dog with me so i'm already
like
you brought your dog to a louis vuitton
store yeah
it's my stroller has two children and a
dog
they're probably like sir you can't come
in here you have to leave the kids
outside they straight up i don't even
think they saw the dog because the dog's
so small and so quiet compared to the
kids like i think that just got lost in
the shuffle otherwise they for sure
would have kicked me out
uh but we were like hey you know um
we're here we're here and we're just
like okay why are you so loud
it's like all right let's do this and i
was so excited just because i was like
all right whatever make this an
experience
and then like five minutes in i became
like i went in with the best intentions
i was like i'm gonna make this a great
experience for my wife she wants this i
i'm gonna not just play along i'm gonna
like be along i'm gonna [__] sing
along with this
and then like literally five to fifteen
minutes in i was just like
all right like just pick one
[Laughter]
it's a small one or the big one i don't
know which one do you like just pick the
one you like
you're such a redneck you're like we're
here and then like five minutes and
we're like hey do you guys sell me like
a lemonade or a turkey leg or anything
i was like oh they used to offer snacks
do you still guys still do that and
they're like we've never done that sir
and i was like all right where the shot
and then like there's no cheez-its there
was like a section for the purses that's
like five stairs up but i got a stroller
two children and a dog as you remember
so i was like y'all got an elevator and
it's like three stairs
they're like uh yeah there is like a
wheelchair lift over here i'm not sure
if your wagon will fit but like and then
i got stuck in the [__] wheelchair
lift going between like going up a four
foot rise
i get stuck and then i realize i'm not
stuck i just pushed the door and it
opens nobody was on the other side to
open the door
it wasn't automatic either dude you're
the indian uh curb your enthusiasm yeah
that's exactly how i felt oh dude
somebody said this the other day they go
um they go i was in l.a
you know i was in l.a or whatever in new
york somewhere
and larry david was there at a a driving
range playing golf
and they were like
um it's and they're like it was like
some like just like a hole in the wall
type of driver not like a nice one
they're like why does larry david go
there he's like oh it's like mirror
where he lives or something so he just
popped over it's like 2 p.m on a tuesday
he just wanted to hit some balls
and they're like i overheard him and
nobody even nobody pays any attention
you know this just looks like an old guy
and nobody knows who he is and he's
talking to the lady who sells it gives
you the balls the balls are
the balls are 11
and he's like
why does he have to be 11 he's like
like he was negotiating the price or
like he was complaining about he's like
a super rich guy he's like
it's not the price eleven dollars now i
gotta have a ten but a ten is not enough
if you made it ten one bill we're done
now i gotta give you a now what are you
gonna give me five and then four once
what am i gonna do with these ones
it's like
like an actual curb your enthusiasm
skills i would definitely like that in
real life
for sure
um
all right since we're talking about
entertainment and content i have to tell
you about two different things so
we're going to call this segment i'm
happy free freaks exist here's the
craziest content that i've consumed this
weekend
have you heard of the show
no yeah no definitely not have you uh
have you seen this show called naked and
afraid
i've heard of it but i have not watched
it it's like it's the craziest thing
right
no
it's worse than that
so what they do is they take two
strangers
and they drop them off in like the
jungle in south africa or
asia i don't even know where the exact
locations are it's all over the world
but like remote remote locations
oftentimes places that's like 110
degrees during the day and like 50
degrees at night so you're freezing they
take two strangers they put them uh in
this area okay they give them nothing
sometimes if the water's really bad
they'll give them just a a
a pot just an empty pot
and and a machete that's basically it
and they make the two strangers meet and
work together to survive for 21 days and
they're completely butt naked
they're they're not wearing anything
they're entirely naked and they've got
to like spoon at night to stay warm
otherwise they're going to like shiver
and like and like is it it's not like
two dudes to women makes what are we it
could be
usually so usually uh like a man and a
woman but then they like throw like
curveballs in there so like they had
this like guy i think he was from
australia and they played him out like
he's like this like redneck hick guy
from australia and then the woman is a
transsexual and she comes on and the
they set it up so like they like you
know how is this conservative guy gonna
feel about this and he was totally and
like the whole show it was like oh you
know it's okay like everyone's like
unique and
and he's like totally kind and like it's
like oh man he's breaking the
stereotypes and they like hug it out and
they're like we'll protect one another
we're team and so that's like you know
like one of many ways the show is
amazing is like they're like doing this
together it's ridiculous and the hardest
thing i've ever seen and i don't think
they get paid a cent even you have to
watch this show it's ridiculous
and so
they have to survive for how long
21 days
21 days and so what are they doing
they're going and hunting or they're
just like eating uh they're like
usually they're like we have to make
shelter they're like we have to go
figure out how to make a fire
sometimes it's in a rain forest and it's
raining and they're like i don't know
how we're going to stay warm we're not
going to eat and so sometimes they won't
eat for days or 10 days
uh on one episode a guy made a bow and
arrow and shot a bird it was awesome um
another episode a guy tried to go and
wrestle a crocodile to bring back and to
eat um
often times i've noticed another uh
like trait i've noticed is usually the
women are way tougher and way calmer
like significantly like the men are like
come out all aggressive like this is
gonna be awesome and they're like trying
to cheer the woman on like let's do this
and then they like get worn out after
seven days and they bail and the woman
just stays by herself and does it uh so
usually the it seems that women are
mentally uh stronger
uh it's amazing this it's a it's a it's
a wild show i cannot believe that like
people do this okay that's amazing uh
what does that have to do with uh
you put a tweet in here also next to it
that's completely unrelated but i guess
it's under the theme of i'm i'm glad
that freaks exist
the second thing there's this guy what's
his name is his name felix felix
what's the url of his website you know
is it like felix today how is felix dot
today
so this freaking guy
for eight years he tracked hundreds of
different parts of his life so and i
have a list up so he tracked the easy
ones like weight
steps and diet but then uh and then
alcohol but then he tracked his mood his
stress he used rescue dot me rescue time
i think it's called an app that tracks
which programs he was using on his
computer how much time he spent on his
cell phone his mood his energy his sleep
uh how often he how many texts he sent
that day how often he talked to friends
um if he was more productive in the
evening or the day
if he took any drugs um what city he was
in what the weather was how hungry he
felt did he feel lethargic did he feel
stressed
uh what else did he it was like just
so much stuff he had 30 or 40 or 50 000
data points and it's all done in an
engineer-like way where it you know he
could say like well i was 46
more likely to say i felt sad if i
didn't see a friend in the trailing
three days like there's like what what
are can can you read out some of the
findings yes so like for example how how
does longer sleep duration like how does
sleep affect my day he's like if i have
um
let's see so if he had more than eight
and a half hours
okay i think i think he means less here
but he's 65 percent more likely to have
cold symptoms 60 more likely to have a
headache he uses social media 40 more
when he sleep deprived
um
30 more likely to be a rainy day that's
interesting
um
yeah crazy stuff 20 less likely to hit
the gym
actually no longer sleep duration this
is so i didn't read it wrong he's saying
if i sleep more than eight and a half
hours all those things are true
um which is great read another one read
some of the other ones it like it's
pretty this is it's pretty amazing what
you found but then
air quality and various rooms like i'm
not even going to read what goes beyond
that but just like measuring the air
quality is crazy
uh wow
this is wild i'm i'm scrolling i've been
scrolling for like
the entire time you were talking and i'm
halfway
through this guy's
findings this guy's he's not is he okay
he's a nut this guy's a freak the funny
thing is he tracked everything and i'm
like is this guy okay i don't think he's
okay i need an answer it should start at
the top is he okay and actually it says
felix feels all right and updated one
hour ago and it says what city he's in
it's
amazing this first little table is nice
wait height sleep and then it goes
last meditated 41 days ago inbox 20
emails personal to-do lists 179 tasks
wow
it's pretty wild
is a sleeping heart rate 459 beats per
minute
so if you scroll all the way to the
bottom he's got one sentence that kind
of like summarizes this
and he says do like a con my computer's
not working but if you do like a control
f build
or something like that you might find it
where he says basically
building this
and having all this information i'm
happy i did it because it's just like a
fun way for me to nerd out but it was
not beneficial and it doesn't make sense
for anyone else to do this
so you were saying
the main it says the main conclusion is
that it is not worth building your own
solution and investing this much time
um so that's on the building your own
solution
uh i'm very happy that i built this
project in the first place it gave me
much better awareness of everything
going on in my life
uh i'm excited i'm excited to have this
uh have built this website to wrap up
this project and showcase some outcomes
so he's done this for eight years you
said
yeah
wow
[Laughter]
amazing right
yeah truly amazing how'd you find this
guy
on twitter how is felix dot today if you
want to go check it out it's nice it's
amazing it's actually pretty nice i'm
not gonna lie
it's awesome it's totally unnecessary
and absolutely amazing like i would like
to have this if i just could do no work
or like you know touch a button once
every five hours like you know i'm down
to do that but i don't want to remember
to log all this stuff his story and so
this guy's incredibly interesting his
story i i read i like researched a lot
of them because i i thought he was
amazing he said he moved where does it
say where he's from is he from vienna or
somewhere like that yeah and he moved to
san francisco in 2015 to work at twitter
and then after a year he was like you
know i don't really like having an
apartment i'm only going to live on an
airbnb
in san francisco and then he was like
i'm just gonna leave san francisco and
so for the past
like seven years he's only like he
doesn't own anything other than a
suitcase i think
and that's how he's been living
good for him i like it i like the uh i
like the segment too i'm glad that
freaks exist can i tell you about
uh another freak
yeah
all right elon musk so the the but this
is not actually about elon this is about
his wife have you ever
stumbled down the rabbit hole
that is justine musk on quora
she talks a lot of crap she
airs out a lot of their she's she like
is it sounds like elon didn't treat her
wonderfully and she lets the world know
like she airs out their laundry
well i don't know i don't know about all
that what did she do that that aired out
as laundry i'm not sure that that's true
she said that he was driven and
everything but she also said like uh
i don't want to exactly paraphrase i
don't remember entirely but i remember
like she gave like a ted talk and on
quora she's like
yeah it's just like living with him was
horrible because he wasn't there he
clear we were all like second and third
place to his work
yeah yeah so she says things that you
would
that's not airing out of dirty laundry
yes i don't know just come that's common
sense almost uh
he's had like three wives i'm pretty
sure you know something's
not great about the experience otherwise
you know
may have lasted for longer uh but dude i
find her
her quora to be fascinating she has
and it's not all just oh let me tell you
about elon musk it's like you know she
answers questions about a bunch of stuff
and she's done it for six years an
author seven years yes so she's an
author she's very smart novelist um and
so she answers some questions i will
give you a couple of the the answers
that she gave so somebody said how can i
be as great as bill gates steve jobs
elon musk or
uh or richard branson and so
uh where's her answer
let me find it
have you been watching the johnny depp
trial
a little bit dude
it's wow so good
it's so good it's so exciting why are
people why is this so fascinating to
people there is okay you want to know
another freaks exist uh moment
go to um
go to this instagram account before i
even go back to this justine musk thing
this is crazy and this is also like kind
of interesting i wouldn't have guessed
that this is a thing but go to the
instagram account that's called
what is it called how is habit or
something like that it's called what's
it called house inhabit
so this person
jessica reed krauss wow what are the
odds both of them felix krauss and
jessica krauss maybe they're married
these two freaks
so she lives in southern california
uh and she calls herself the queen of
the carpool the hollywood philosopher
uh stereotypical scorpio tendencies and
then she puts her venmo on here just to
give you a quick sense of what we're
dealing with okay so what's the scorpio
i don't understand what that route is
all like la
things it's like you know here's my
favorite crystal here's my horoscope
here's my venmo and here's my casting
tape
so um all right so she basically covers
trial like hollywood gossip but in the
craziest amount of detail you'll ever
see so look at her father account she's
got 850 000 followers that's just like
an independent person
and she's been posting every day about
the trial like if you go click her story
there's like 50 like maybe more oh my
god there's like 80 story frames right
to like tap through and she edits it
like crazy it's like insane so like um
today's not a good one because it's like
there wasn't like a trial thing but like
if you click like 10 in
it'll be like she'll cut like a little
clip of johnny walking in and then
there's music she overlays and then
there's like a little thing that she
cuts in this news clip from fox and then
she adds on top of that then she
transcribes a whole bunch of stuff and
like puts the transcript there then she
does the background research and so i
know several people who are following
the whole trial they don't watch
a single minute of the trial they don't
read the news they just follow it
through her story because it because it
is so crazy in depth and somewhat
addictive and entertaining and like
first when the first person told me i
was like okay that's weird whatever you
you got into something weird then i
heard it again and i was like you also
follow that random person and the yeah
it's great and then i looked at then i
looked him up and she has 850 000
followers and i was like holy [__] this
is crazy that this is like
one of those niches that you wouldn't
even really know exists but of course it
exists and of course it's a big deal it
basically takes the tabloid but it
repackages it from a tabloid into like
any individual person's instagram can
become
the juiciest tabloid in the world if you
just put in the effort and she puts in
mad effort
what she just covered i was looking at
her stories that there was a guy a
couple of days ago he looked like he was
dressed like he was about to go to be a
waiter at a restaurant and he couldn't
be at the trial so he was on zoom and he
was in his car
and he was sitting there with the zoo
with this camera from him and he starts
vaping
on the call and you see him like take a
hit of vape and like exhale all this
smoke while he's sitting in his car
waiting for the judge to ask a question
and then uh it's clear that like he's
got to go so he starts driving out of
the parking lot like while and vaping
while he's answering the calls and he's
like all right you guys good dance it's
everything all right i gotta go he's
just
he's like like vaping while driving away
during this trial but uh all right what
about justine
okay so justine musk okay so somebody
asked will i become a billionaire if i'm
determined to be one and i put in the
necessary work
uh
her first answer no
one of the qualities of a self-made
billionaire is their ability to ask the
right question that is not the right
question it's not to say it's a bad
question it just won't get you to the
part of your mind uh that's working to
help you and mulling things over while
you're doing up other things and sending
up flares of insight
you're determined so what you haven't
been you haven't been racing naked
through shark infested waters yet will
you be determined when you wash up on
some deserted island disoriented bloody
ragged beaten staring off into the
horizon with no sign of rescue and she's
like so she goes through and she's like
you know
the world doesn't hit like the final
thing the world doesn't throw a billion
dollars at the person because they want
it or because they work so hard they
feel they deserve it the world does not
know doesn't care what you want or
deserve the world gives you in exchange
for something it perceives to be of
equal or greater value
and um anyway so she goes through and
and basically like you know the long
story short was no a billionaire doesn't
come on cora and ask these types of
questions uh but it'll be like if you
just go through and deep dive
dive through to search her on on on
quora and
it's a fun like 20 minute read because i
think you get little snapshots into
somebody who knows elon musk really well
and has been around somebody of that
like you know kind of like the greatest
entrepreneur and inventor of our
lifetime
um somebody who knows them from a
different angle but then also somebody
who's just like smart and objective so
they're not a fanboy
nor are they a hater
it's like someone who
i actually kind of respect and
you know believe their opinion on these
things obviously everybody's got their
bias but i feel like with elon musk
normally it's 100 fanboy or 100 hater um
or just completely uninformed and like
this is none of the above this is
something else this is informed are
there any other good ones
that she's written up
uh yeah there's a bunch that are just on
so i started with the elon ones and then
it'll be like you know um
you know i'll be like you know should i
how should i break up with my girlfriend
it's like let's see what she has to say
about that and like you just read like
you know her kind of take on philosophy
i don't know she's a fascinating
character the other one is grimes just
did a podcast with lex friedman i don't
know if you saw saw that
i heard about it
so elon's current i don't know what i
don't know if they're married girlfriend
something baby mama i think they've had
two babies together but they're not
married or something like that they're
not together anymore uh she did a
podcast and you could definitely see
like
how
these people would get along like she
even talks like elon in this kind of
like slow measured
weird
like finality type of way of speaking uh
but she was talking about like you know
um
like how to raise kids or like you know
looks like they're like you know what do
you think about like you know uh free
speech on twitter or something like that
lex tried to ask her and she's like
i
i do not think i should have an opinion
on this
he's like oh my god and then which is
like such an elon thing to say she's
like i feel you know i'm too close to
the situation i actually i should not
have an opinion on this
i should i shouldn't have an opinion on
this
oh my god
[Laughter]
it would not be it would not not be
productive to this future of humanity
does she come off that weird
kind of yeah it's like not like i
thought i don't know i knew nothing
about her so like you know by just
uh from afar is like oh i think he
married like a musician or something
like that okay she's probably like
you know like some
you know just like beautiful happy
bubbly pop star and it's like no it's
not that at all okay she's kind of like
alternative all right i get it but still
you know like
i don't know charismatic charismatic and
into
like uh just like kind of like a
extrovert people person
and instead it was like you know she was
like oh uh
they were like how's it been you know
like tell me about like you just had a
baby you know what's what's mother had
been like for you or whatever and she's
like it reminds me of my favorite uh
graphic novel sci-fi graphic novel um
uh and then she named some japanese like
graphic novel you know like no one's
she's like have you read it and he's
like no and then she's like it's called
um i have no mouth but i must scream and
that's awesome and that's what having
this baby feels like because they're
helpless right they can't even control
their muscles they move they can't say
what they want they can't express what
they need but they need something and
they're trying to scream but it's as if
they have no mouth i was like whoa like
pretty dark take on like motherhood but
like i don't know also interesting and
insightful at the same time
um but yeah that's been kind of my like
that's that's my contribution to the uh
i'm happy that that freaks exist because
like yeah i'm happy that there's people
that are so different
and um
so interesting and we will live life in
a way that's like interesting but like
uncomfortable and i get to be
comfortable and just watch them do
interesting things
like you know that dude i love it that
teddy roosevelt quote that everybody all
every entrepreneur loves to put on
[__] insulin like the
the man in the arena
it is not the critic who couch it's the
man in the arena who's bloody and beaten
and whatever you know what it's also
tight to not be bloody and beat it's
time to be
just a casual fan in the arena eating
popcorn watching other people get beaten
up and then going back to your daily
life like that's actually a pretty tight
position that like most people should go
into and not try to be like you know the
gladiator dying in the arena or the
critic hater you don't need to be either
one
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
dude do you realize that to some people
i think you and i are that entertainment
where
like i'll have some people like reach
out to me and i think it happens to you
it's like oh you should do blank it's
like you really just want me to dance
for you yeah that's really yeah
just tell me to dance that would be a
lot easier that'll only take a few
minutes you want me to dedicate three
years of my life to starting blank
yeah you guys should talk about this oh
you want me to go get a phd in something
i don't know about
okay cool
that's not how the podcast works but
here's how the podcast works
i'm weird and don't realize it then i
come talk to sam he's weird and doesn't
realize it then we kind of point out oh
that's weird about each other then we go
away and like you guys think we're both
weird
[Laughter]
yeah i mean we are that to some people
where they're just like want us to dance
um but dude that's why i love the the
youtubers like there's this guy i've
been following i think it's called like
whistling diesel there's all these
youtubers where uh they got they get
what does that pretty cool
whistling i think it's whistling diesel
so he like has all this acreage out in
indiana i think and he just uh
like builds cool trucks and cars and
just like wrecks them basically uh like
you know he'll build like um
remember as a kid i think it was called
the power wheel it's like the like the
little toy trucks for kids where you
like sit in it he'll build one i'll take
one of those it's not really one of
those but he like builds a version of
that that has a massive gas engine in it
it goes like 120 miles an hour
but it looks like a power wheel so just
like doing things that like you think
you would want to do in the country but
what's in or you know when you're out
in the land and like just breaking [__]
and like blowing stuff up doing all that
but what's crazy is these guys do it and
then they start making money from it and
they're like all right now we have more
money to spend
bigger stuff to blow stuff up and to
build stuff like or there's all these
guys on youtube who will like get like a
50 caliber rifle so like this gun that's
like huge and scary and they're like you
think it can shoot through that car
like let's just try it let's see if
it'll go straight through the car or
what would happen if we just shot this
at like a huge block of metal how deep
will it go like just all these like
stupid stuff that you would just only do
like either when you're high or you just
dream of but you're afraid of losing all
this money they do it and i get to live
through them and i love that wow
that's cool they're actually kind of
related note uh so mr beast basically
does this but he's like exactly and you
know he's almost like a hundred million
subscribers on youtube so did you see
this thing that was going on last night
i i doubt you did because it's like you
know you said you're gen y this is like
gen z you know [__] but basically there
was a celebrity poker game last night
with
basically
it was this public game last night that
had like i don't know how many like 50
000 or more
people watching it live
um streamed on on twitch and youtube and
it had mr beast who's the number one
youtuber uh like or whatever
one of the biggest youtubers ninja who
was the biggest streamer for like a long
period of time xqc who's the biggest uh
like one of the biggest twitch streamers
also there's basically like four or five
huge content creators
then it was phil hellmuth who's this
like famous like pro poker player that's
on tv all the time tom dwan who's like
one of the greatest poker players ever
so it's like a couple of pros and a
couple of uh content creators and they
came in it was a 50 000 buy-in game but
they could rebuy and so it was called
the million dollar game and basically
this was being live stream last night
and none of them were like playing
seriously because they were like hey
they're all rich and b they were trying
to make for good content um and so they
were like they played this game it was
very entertaining game it was probably
like the one of the most entertaining
like uh
i don't know like online or like uh tv
poker games that i've seen like in a
long time
and uh i just thought it was a great
idea that's a that's a pretty short list
i would imagine though
no i've been watching for a long time so
i i actually care about about online
about poker and have watched a bunch of
like world series of pokers or so what
happened so basically uh shout out to to
our girl alexander botez do you know her
she's the chess girl
okay i i did a pie oh yeah we've talked
about her i did a podcast yeah so she's
uh a streamer content creator who's like
her and her sister i don't think they're
twins but i think they're they're
sisters they um
they're like chess mat like i don't know
if they're grandmaster or their master
players or whatever but they're like
they're like great at chess but also
great at content so they have like a big
following or whatever
and so she just cleaned up in this game
and she's not like a great poker player
it's just like
they would they were all kind of playing
very loose and she won like a half a
million dollar pot like you know
just kind of like with ace nine that's
like kind of like a lucky hand or
whatever and uh the pros were sitting
there like just kind of waiting for a
good car like waiting for good to play
good cards or just playing smart whereas
mr beast was like just playing kind of
like ever any hand he could get into
and then he'd be like
he's just he's like i just want one clip
to go viral like that's what i'm here
for is for one clip to go viral because
they're like i can poke or you could do
this thing where once both people go all
in you could say all right
normally you would just there's only one
card left and like
one of us will win one of us to lose but
you could do something called running it
twice which kind of like smoothens out
the like um
the variability like it's like running
multiple times in a simulation so you'll
get like more possible outcomes so you
can run it once run it twice running
three times one or four times
and he's like no we're gonna run it once
he's like we need this clip to go viral
it needs to be the highest stakes with
the biggest heartbreak and like the
easiest to understand and you can see
the poker pros were like
oh okay like i guess so i guess that
makes makes sense it's like to be so
funny just to see uh these guys playing
with totally different like agendas
and styles and also they were mic'd up
the whole time
and there was no edits because it was
live and so you could just hear them
like bullshitting about whatever to each
other and like you know people from
different worlds kind of just like
so you do this like i was like so like
you know uh how much how often do you
play he's like
oh i've been i don't play like this is
the first day off i've taken in four
years
he's like what do you mean like uh how
often do you stream because i stream
every day for 10 hours a day
he's like what he's like yeah and he's
like uh this is one of the few like one
of the rare
this guy xqc and there and they're like
how long have you been do that for like
seven years
i don't understand the poker player
looked at the streamer like you
degenerate which is hilarious because
the poker player is normally like the
biggest degenerate who sits at a table
playing you know this like stupid card
game for five hours straight losing
money is that real well someone will
someone really stream for seven years
every single day for 10 hours yeah yeah
that happens uh like not 10 usually it's
not those exact numbers but people have
streamed every day for 10 years and
they'll stream like five hour streams or
something like that as like their their
normal stream and some guys do 10 hour
streams and then they'll usually take
one day off a week maybe actually i
don't know
specifics but like
yeah he he he's a like he's a nut
and when he's streaming what's he doing
he's playing video games
any game so he yeah he was like big in
overwatch but then overwatch stopped
getting like popular but he got more
popular because his personality is
pretty big like he just kind of gets
wild on the stream
and so now he'll go he'll do whatever
he'll play in a virtual farm simulator
he'll play like you know a shooting game
he'll play like whatever the game is he
calls himself a variety streamer which
is basically like at that point they've
stopped coming for the game and they're
coming for you
and is he funny like yeah what what he's
what's great about him
uh he's funny and he like he like rage
he like gets enraged pretty quickly
which is like a big thing on twitch is
like you gotta like show emotion so like
you see in basketball or like golf is
the ultimate example of this uh and this
is where i think traditional sports can
learn a lot from online content because
traditional sports they teach you like
if you ever watch a basketball press
conference they're the most boring in
the world it's like yeah we're just
gonna take it one game at a time you
know they're a great team add respect to
them uh you know we just gotta
keep putting one foot in front of the
other it's like oh great you know like
super boring whereas you you and i love
ufc because that one guy would be like
he ain't [__] i'm gonna kick his team
his ass and his whole team's ass you
know like they just like they like talk
[__] to each other so that adds a level
of like drama and excitement streaming
is like that but like 24 7 where they're
just constantly you know
talking [__] to them to their teammates
about themselves about you know the game
about like the characters about the
strategy about whatever so they show a
ton of emotion so if he loses he'll
throw the mouse he'll break the keyboard
he'll like you know like spit and scream
and you know like he'll get angry how
does he have enough energy to do that
every single day
it's just what he does man it's like he
that's and you just sit and he's sitting
in a chair for he's sitting at a chair
for 10 hours a day look different yeah
yeah
you may not like this
but it is peak physical performance
exactly somebody said this thing
there was this hilarious line during the
thing so she won the the alexander won
the 500 000 pot and then she like won
another pot she was like up 600 grand
she came in with 50k and she had like a
650 000 chip stack and like she had so
many chips she couldn't even stack them
in time like the next hand needed to be
dealt but her giant her giant chip stack
was just blocking the tap the table and
she's like um i need help stacking the
chips and they were like [__] you we're
not gonna help you stack your chips you
just took from us and like the pit boss
comes over they're helping and then mr
peace goes
she's single-handedly gonna close the
wage gap
yeah they're just trolls and uh
it's just amazing it was amazing and i
just thought that was a great idea by
the way i like a
like a high stakes poker game amongst
personalities in any niche i actually
think that's a good marketing idea
this one streamer who we're talking
about what's his name
uh xqc in this case
how much money does he make
he probably makes between
i want to say three to ten million
dollars a year
no way really
yeah
probably five to ten years is the easy
estimate um
ten man ten is not even the upper bound
like they
these guys can make much more than that
maybe
up to 20 25 million if they are
maxing out their stuff but they don't
always want to do that like uh i taught
because i used to negotiate with these
guys so you know um
even before twitch like when i was just
trying to get them to promote our
products
and it's like all right i'm going to
talk to i want to talk to the streamer
like no you don't get to talk to the
streamer you talk to the manager okay
fair that's fine there's stars i get it
all right who's the manager is it like
you know caa or like wme and like for 95
percent of them it's like oh it's like
his little brother ray ray yeah that was
his girlfriend or like you know exactly
it's ray ray or like
oh hey jenny um you know
so how long you guys been working
together it's like well we've moved in
together like when we were 16 and then
like he
didn't do anything for five years just
played video games all the time and like
now he's rich and so i quit my job to
like check his email because they'll be
they'll be like yeah we do like brand
deals i'm like cool so like do you have
like a deck you guys can share about
like you know his stats they're like
no you could just like go on and see how
many people watch them it's like a lot
and it's like it's like so like you have
this deal with like red bull like
logitech like surely you have like a
brand and like
like you know when you pitch them like
we don't pitch anybody like like
basically and you know as i got to know
people it's like
they just get inbound into their email
and then they just decide they ignore 95
of it even though it's people literally
throwing them like like people can get
paid
uh
like the small even like like less high
profile like ninja is a different tier
right ninja does have a proper manager
and like actually his girlfriend i think
is his manager now his wife uh but like
he had a proper agency behind him and
they pitched red bull and all this stuff
but like most streamers somebody will
approach and be like hey i'll pay you
2000 an hour to play my game today
and they're like nah that game looks
boring i'm not gonna do it right because
like they don't want to lose their
audience or like piss off their audience
too much or be seen as selling out and
so they turned down so many
opportunities that they could have
because they don't want to be seen as a
sellout nor do they want to like bother
with anything it's like dude by the time
i'm done streaming for 10 hours like
imagine doing this podcast 10 hours a
day or eight hours a day you have zero
energy left to like do anything else and
so you just like you don't want to even
think about it
so
and do a lot of them have any expenses
so or are they just paying taxes and
rent and they're just stacking cash
yeah that's exactly it
some of these streamers i mean they
could be worth 30 or 40 million dollars
liquid yeah
that's crazy isn't it yeah like uh ninja
got paid you know i can't say the number
but stupid money to go stream on mixer
like a competitor to twitch i think it
got leaked i think the number got leaked
because uh something happened yeah maybe
i think
i think twitch got hacked and like all
the spreadsheet got out remember you
know i'm talking about well that's the
that's pretty visible anyways that's
that's just what they earn directly so
basically like the fans subscribe five
dollars a month or six dollars a month
or whatever to the channel
in order to
like
kind of just like show their support and
get like special emojis that they get to
use
and uh sometimes the streamer can turn
around where subscriber only chat
but um
but for the most part like they get
donations that
that most people can't see how much
donations they get
uh then they get subscribers directly
that's a monthly recurring subscription
then there's brand deals and sponsors
that didn't show up in the twitch thing
because that goes direct and it's like
they just pay the streamer directly it's
not part of twitch and so there's like
other
uh and then you know games come to them
and pay them hey we're doing a brand
launch we want all ten of the big
streamers all playing valerian today and
they'll drop you know five million
dollars on that campaign because they
know that if they do that they become
the it game and millions of people will
get to see their favorite streamer
playing the game and saying how awesome
it is or whatever showing it off and so
it's worth it to them because they're
going to make way more than that
have you seen intro.com have you been
intro.com
yeah i looked at investing in it but i
decided not to so i talked to the guy
who started like i went to uh i went to
like a car racing class and he like a
friend of a friend brought him and i had
to hang out with him he's a cool guy and
he was like hey just sign up for intro
dot com and basically what it you do is
you just like put that you're available
a certain hours amount of uh certain
hours a week and someone will pay you
like two thousand dollars an hour
in 15 minute incr increments to talk to
you and i was like i don't know man i
feel kind of sleazy doing that and he
was like well just try and i was like
okay well you know you seem nice
whatever i'll kind of do it just to like
geek out and try this new product and i
signed up for it and i've been getting
bookings like crazy
and between i'm i'm at the phase now a
little bit where
you know it's coming up on uh this
july will be a year and a half since the
acquisition
uh it's like
yeah
[Laughter]
how many years you've been married i
have no idea how many years ago
year and a half 16 months
it's like well which uh
which time zone are we are we thinking
here because i can tell you
uh
so it's coming up to that time and i'm
like
all right do i like start a new company
what am i going to do uh what should i
be doing and i sign up to intro and
we're doing this and i got that little
copy that thing and i got like this
airbnb and i'm like
well besides like the fact that like i
could live off interest like off my nut
i'm like
that's kind of cool like there's all
this income coming in
there's so much and i'm not trying to
like
i'm trying to do this like brag [__] but
i'm saying like for a creator that has a
mildly big audience there are so many
ways to make money it's pretty
astounding and we're not even that i
mean we're just like semi-popular and a
relatively small niche
so like let alone if you're like these
twitch guys and you you're you're
actually really popular but it's pretty
astounding how many like revenue streams
are available to us just because of all
these this like weird all these creator
type tool things totally like i saw uh
some guy tweeted today he goes bro at
elon musk give me my blue check back and
had like 80 000 likes i was like who is
this guy he's like he's a
soccer player at like man city or
something like that and i was like and
he's got like millions of followers i
was like wow you know like it's like
there's so many levels of fame like that
guy's not famous at all compared to like
you know justin bieber or whatever and
justin bieber's not famous compared to
whoever but like
you know down if you go 20 rungs down
the ladder
it's like we're like
moderately known in a tiny niche and
then i sent you that link of that those
guys who discuss like uh they're like
bodybuilders or something like that are
they they're discussing like working out
or something like that they're like wait
wait guessing setup
oh uh yeah i was on their podcast
they're awesome what
yeah yeah i was on their podcast a
couple years ago the uh mind body
wow is it mind body pump or just mind
body
that's the ultimate resume for your uh
for your fitness influencer career
i did it looking at youtube yeah they
were like i think that video had like i
don't know i want to say 80 000 views or
150 000 views or something like that but
just not like you hear of bigger numbers
but that's big that's like
we get less than that on our youtube
and i feel like we're big now they're
big and they're in just like another
niche but their niche lets them do a lot
more because more broad appeal like
there's a bunch of dudes out there who
want to be like more muscular like
people want to lose weight and so
you know they can flip on one you know
white labeled supplement or course or
whatever the heck they want
and you know that that type of following
can print
uh i don't know
again five to ten million dollars a year
for sure profitably you know without
like
the stress of being an entrepreneur
trying to invent a new product and go
into a new niche and then it also has a
bunch of downsides right like the guys
streaming 10 hours a day for seven years
straight like the biggest problem with
content is you're usually on a treadmill
and like you know you feel like you
can't get off like twitch streamers have
this all the time or they feel burnt out
because they're just like they feel like
if they stop they'll lose everything and
it's true if they stop they actually do
lose quite a bit of like
uh you know like sway with not only you
know their subscribers but the algorithm
and things like that
so you know i think that's the downside
of these models
you have to build a business that's
beyond that so those guys the what's it
called the uh i listen to it all the
time i'm totally blanking mind body pump
is that what it's with sal and adam uh
it's like the they're based out of a
sacramento so they um
they just bought a bunch of airbnb they
bought a bunch of properties and they're
turning them into fitness airbnbs and so
that's like a good example that well it
will it'll extend beyond them but uh
yeah i mean like what do you do like
have there been any examples i think you
know who jenna marbles is
yeah
so she's like she was got popular in my
mind when she was on barstool and then
she bailed and went to youtube and
became like one of the biggest youtubers
of all time i'm pretty sure that she
like got her cash and got her money and
i don't even think she posts anymore
even though she has
many many tens of millions of
subscribers how many i my internet's
slow so i can't even pull it up how many
subscribers yeah she's got a ton on
youtube i think it's like 50 or 60
million she was one of the first people
to get popular i feel like she got
popular like
i want to even say before youtube she
got 19 million subscribers she's been on
for 10 years uh when was her last video
i have no idea uh is she still posting
regularly i don't think she posts per
post regularly but she has a a brand of
dog toys called kermie and worm and mr
marbles um
so she was one of she she's had 20 if
she said she has 20 million or 18
million she's had that forever and i'm
pretty sure she's just like made her
money and bailed
and just left
yeah like her last video was one year
ago
it was casey neistat did that too right
he was
vlogging every day and then he got paid
and he just says i'm out
yeah
it's the way to go so i think if you're
on on that intense of a treadmill it's
it's pretty tough if you can't like you
know get you out of it by the way
there's a guy who
tweeted at us he's like i i think he
listens to the podcast um i'm gonna find
his like exact details later uh because
it's hard to just twitter dm searches
like impossible
but basically there's a guy who's just
buying up
uh youtube channels that are non-faced
non-face youtube channels such as
they're branded as something else
um so there's no jenna marbles there's
no personality to it and uh he buys
these up for
you know he basically you know he's just
looking at their youtube like uh
he's looking at their youtube like you
know revenues or whatever and he's like
cool i'll make you this offer so i can
uh i can buy this thing out for this
much or whatever
and uh and it's like interesting i
hadn't really heard of somebody rolling
up youtube channels like that but i
think that's a
pretty cool niche i think
that would be a good idea i think if you
did it with a face it'd be a horrible
idea because i imagine that if you could
make a list of people who you'd like to
have work for you a youtuber would be
incredibly low on that list
well yeah right it's hard to buy them
out right because they you know they no
longer have the motivation to uh
to create content and then you're stuck
because you can't just be like hey it's
me now
i'm here
yeah it's me louis vuitton i'm here
all right what else do we want to do
uh
let's do one other random one dude so
have you ever filed for a trademark uh
yourself
it's kind of a pain in the butt in it i
think i had a lawyer do it yeah but i
like went through i tried originally
like
bootstrapping it and just like do it on
my own i didn't know how to do it so i
get this i get this letter so this
letter comes in the mail uh six months
after we file
it's from this company called i don't
know if you can see this wtp
i'm like oh
maybe it sounds about it it's about our
yeah sounds legit uh it says at the top
trademark publications and it's got our
company name our address and it says
reference number blah blah blah
application date blah blah
classes blah blah blah
and then it has a giant thing of our
trademark and it says here's your fee
for uh 1 420 please pay the amount on
acceptance within ten days by check
don't forget to quote your reference
number make it payable to a scam wtp
um like oh cool but i thought i uh
pretty sure i already paid for the
trademark so who who is this what's this
for and then here's what it says in the
like look at this uh fine print here in
the bottom
yeah in the bottom
box here so like you see this like size
three print
uh so here's what this says dear madame
or sir oh now you're sounding like my
uncle in india writing an email to me
dude anytime i get a dear sir i know
it's i know it's not good yeah
a dear sir and uh i hate mine
dear sucka
um all right so it says the publication
of your public registration is
the publication of your public
registration of your trademark is the
basis of our offer
what does that mean
all they're going to do is just
publicize that we have made a trademark
that's what they're charging me for 1400
for do they work for the trademark
office no it says so here's what it says
this is an offer for free entry into our
database www www.wptw
register.com this is not an invoice you
are not required to pay the above amount
unless you accept this offer all of the
details in our general terms and
conditions right it's like what a scam
and you know all they do is they just
monitor every trademark filing which is
like yeah gotta be you know i don't know
whatever tens of thousands a year
and then they just send this letter out
and they're just fishing for a sucker
they're fishing dude it's just like sir
out there the the car and the one sir
yes sir short for sucker
they're just looking for uh have you
seen the car warranty or home warranty
[__]
no is it the same
it's the same thing have you ever met
anyone who runs one of these scams
no if i did i'd give them a strong
talking to
it would be really fun to like just like
uh
have you seen on the office they go uh
michael scott has to ask a question but
he can't sound mean and instead of
saying how do you sleep at night he just
says
how do you sleep at night that's just
like that and that's like what
like it's like
like the bosses are around but toby's
leaving and then he's gotta change his
question to like
where do you get off
[Laughter]
who do you think you are
that's like the type of questions i want
to ask these people what do you like
what do you how do you go to bed at
night knowing that you're just uh that's
one question to you wtp
how do you
sleep at night
yeah that's what we want to know here at
michael you sleep at night
that's amazing all right we can wrap it
up there i had a bunch of ideas we
didn't talk about any of them but that's
okay we'll do it next spot
[Music]
you